bonjour à tous en ce mardi 27 septembre
quelques points d'agenda pour commencer
outre le point presse qui vient comme
vous attendu content d'être inauguré
laurent wauquiez le notre président des
républicains se rendra en réunion
publique ce soir à 19h30 à rouen et ira
vendredi prochain à saint jean de
maurienne en savoie à l'occasion d'une
rencontre départementale
nous souhaitions tous les 4 commence
évidemment ce point presse avec ce qui
fait la une de l'actualité pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens qu'ils
vivent au quotidien c'est les chiffres
absolument catastrophiques du chômage
deux chiffres fondamentaux à retenir au
lieu de de ces pseudo analyse plus 52
mille chômeurs au mois d'août dernier
premiers chiffres et deuxièmement en
cumulé depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
françois hollande c'est près d'un
million deux cent mille chômeurs
supplémentaires résultat de la politique
socialiste
alors on nous parle depuis ces quatre
dernières années de la courbe du chômage
je vais pas vous refaire tout
l'historique et le et le roman de
françois hollande on a une certitude
ce matin c'est que la courbe du mensonge
et de l'incompétence ne s'inversera
jamais et en particulier sur ces
questions là puisque nous assistons à un
véritable waterloo du travail et pire on
en parlait ce matin des uns et les
autres avec le ressenti de nos
concitoyens il y a eu le temps de
l'impuissance
puis le temps de l'incompétence et
désormais nous avons basculé dans le
temps de l'indécence puisque nous donne
des arguties alors cet été c'était la
faute à pas de bol pour citer le
président de la république
désormais ce serait le résultat des
attentats donc on voit bien qu'il ya un
gouvernement qui est dans l'impuissance
publique de manière absolue et nous
souhaitions a ajouté que françois on
n'est pas d'ailleurs le seul en cause
puisque un homme qui donne beaucoup de
leçons de morale et qui propose pour
demain ce qui n'a pas fait hier monsieur
emmanuel macron à laisser au fond un
véritable cadeau de départ
à nos concitoyens puisque ces chiffres
du mois d'août 52 mille chômeurs de plus
c'est aussi son bilan puisqu'il a décidé
de quitter le gouvernement à la fin du
mois d'août et donc on pousse
l'indécence à un niveau jamais atteint
et jamais égalée puisque osé quitter le
ministère de l'économie des finances qui
a la responsabilité majeure de la
politique de l'emploi et de la lutte
contre le chômage
à un moment où on atteint un chiffre
record du nombre de chômeurs est osé
envisager de se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle
fort de ce de ces chiffres
catastrophiques
vraiment on pousse l'indécence
extrêmement loin nous nous avons un
certain nombre de propositions sur
lesquelles nous reviendrons chacun les
connaît sur la baisse des charges
drastique pour les pme un environnement
social sur le code du travail beaucoup
plus allégée beaucoup plus assoupli avec
une vraie réforme du code du travail la
mise et la mise en place et
l'instauration du patriotisme économique
et d'un état stratège au service de nos
pme et de nos entreprises
voilà les mesures que les républicains
proposent depuis des mois et des mois
pour que nous soyons prêts dès l'été
2010 est afin d'offrir une véritable
alternative à la politique socialiste
catastrophiques sur les questions du
chômage et sur toutes les autres et je
passe la parole à annie qui sur le
chômage aussi sur le contexte financier
et budgétaire à une analyse précise à
nous donner alors c'était non c'est déjà
une très mauvaise nouvelle pour les
français pour notre économie
puisque cette aggravation il n'est dit
marc une difficulté qui se précisent de
mois en mois alors j'aurai à dire que
c'est d'autant plus grave que le plan
des 500 milles en formation activé
depuis plusieurs mois produits étaient
censés produire quelques effets ça veut
dire que malgré ce plan qui était censé
vide et substantiellement les catégories
à b et c est bien ce plan ne suffit pas
à enrayer
ça veut dire que s'il n'était pas là la
situation serait encore plus grave
donc on a véritablement une très
mauvaise nouvelle pour notre économie et
pour notre pays
je voudrais dénoncer également le déni
du gouvernement qui attribue la cause
comme l'a dit guillaume aux attentats et
puis à une argutie administrative un
nombre accru d'actualisation enfin tout
ça est assez fumeux la réalité elle est
brutale toutes les catégories repartent
à la hausse
des jeunes aux chômeurs de longue durée
je rappelle que les chômeurs de longue
durée ces derniers n'avaient pas le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi chez les
chômeurs de longue durée n'avait pas
augmenté depuis 2008 donc là on voit
bien qu'il y à une aggravation profonde
et la responsabilité du gouvernement se
mesurent dans la comparaison avec les
autres pays européens
le chômage baisse partout et pas en
france
donc il y a là une manifestation
évidente de la responsabilité du
gouvernement et du président de la
république
on en connaît les causes une fiscalité
confiscatoire des réformes mal fichu
depuis la réforme de la pénibilité
jusqu'à celle de la retenue à la source
rien n'est fait pour simplifier la vie
des entreprises la croissance faiblit il
ya là une cause majeure de la situation
du chômage en france
et lorsque la croissance faiblit c'est
bien la démonstration qu'il n'y a pas de
confiance il n'y a pas d'économie sans
confiance
donc on voit là l'échec patent du
président de la république du
gouvernement et tout cela est très
inquiétant finalement
et très inquiétant pour notre pays
quelques uns derniers chiffres 1 depuis
2012 un million virgule deux chômeurs en
plus c'est absolument considérable nous
avons aujourd'hui 6 millions de
personnes inscrites à pôle emploi
la réalité elle est là dans ce chiffre
absolument dramatique merci annie nous
souhaitons également revenir sur le
déplacement de françois hollande à
calais le président de la république
s'est rendu dans cette ville dont on
sait à quel point elle souffre il faut
rappeler que
avant 2012 il y avait moins de mille
migrants installés à calais
qu'aujourd'hui les chiffres de la police
indique entre 10000 et 12000 personnes
avec pour les habitants de calais une
situation absolument dramatique
aujourd'hui les gens qui sont à
proximité souhaite partir ont leurs
biens immobiliers qui ne vaut
strictement plus rien ils ont donc tout
perdu d'un point de vue personnel sans
compter une situation de violence
importante des difficultés la nuit des
difficultés évidemment de circulation et
puis pour toute la zone portuaire de
calais une économie qui est complètement
en berne le président de la république a
indiqué qu'il s'engageait à vider la
zone de la jungle la zone de calais
aujourd'hui nous disons nous les
républicains ça suffit les mots nous
souhaitons des actes nous n'avons que
des mots depuis six mois
des mots de monsieur 15,9 des mots du
président de la république des mots de
monsieur valls qui d'ailleurs se fait
cruellement absente sur la situation de
calais il faut maintenant des actes et
nous exigeons de ce gouvernement que des
actes formelle clair avec des tattes
soit pris nous voulons savoir quand à
quelle échéance
la jungle de calais va être vidé
ensuite nous interpellons et nous disons
au gouvernement qu'il sera hors de
question pour les républicains
d'accepter que les migrants qui sont
actuellement à calais soient répartis
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
ça serait proprement inadmissible c'est
contraire à la volonté de ces personnes
qui souhaitent aller en angleterre et
c'est évidemment absolument contraire à
la volonté des français des élus nous
dénonçons également la matière le double
langage de monsieur cazeneuve a paris il
dit nous ne prendrons aucune décision
sans les élus locaux
or une circulaire qui a été envoyée au
préfet indique clairement qui n'a pas
qu'il n'est pas besoin de rechercher
l'avis des élus locaux double langage
mensonge supplémentaire c'est une
habitude dans l'équipe de monsieur
hollande mais c'est proprement
inadmissible
nous serons extrêmement vigilants nous
exigeons un la date les modalités de
départ de calais et 2 qui n'est
évidemment aucune ventilation sur le
territoire national deuxième élément sur
lequel nous souhaitons insister à cette
occasion de ce déplacement à calais
monsieur hollande a fait un déplacement
privé pour aller rencontrer des soutiens
pourquoi pas il paraît qu'il est
candidat mais nous interpellons encore
une fois avec quel argent avec quels
moyens comment cela se passe-t-il
il est candidat président président
candidat
nous souhaitons que les choses soient
claires clarifier tout comme d'ailleurs
l'ont demandé monsieur montebourg et
amont et que les moyens de l'état ne
soient pas pris pour faire une campagne
qui ci a le droit d'être faite doit le
faire doit l'être de façon claire le
mensonge de ce gouvernement ne voit pas
aujourd'hui se traduire dans le mensonge
d'une campagne électorale qui s'annonce
merci sur l'actualité européenne
d'abord avant de vous parler de
l'actualité européenne je fais je
rebondis sur calais en vous donnant
cette information que le bundestag a
pris la décision il ya quelques mois
maintenant et c'est en vigueur en
allemagne de traiter d'une manière
nouvelle les demandeurs d'asile qui en
france comme vous le savez la demande
d'asile mais plusieurs mois être
instruite ce qui conduit à un résultat
qui fait qu'on pratique les demandeurs
d'asile même déboutés ne re ne sont pas
reconduits à la frontière
la décision qui a été prise marc et
allemagne est de traiter les demandes en
une semaine avec un droit d'appel qui
doit être traitée dans les 15 jours et
pendant tout ce temps la personne qui
demandent le droit d'asile a le droit à
des prestations sociales des aides de
santé si elle en a besoin bien entendu à
la condition qu'elles acceptent d'être
hébergés dans un centre qui est un
centre contrôlées par l'état fédéral
donc on voit bien qu'il ya réellement
d'eux
façon de traiter les choses une façon
volontariste et une façon qui consiste
en réalité à ne pas décider c'est la
façon française sur l'actualité
européenne de plusieurs choses mais
peut-être un focus sur les deux réunions
qui ont eu lieu depuis dix jours à
bratislava et la première réunion c'est
celle de ya dix jours
réunion des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement et souvenez-vous françois
hollande avait dit je vais à cette
réunion et je vais dénoncer le traité
transatlantique nous allons arrêter les
négociations
je vous invite à regarder aussi bien la
conférence de presse commune entre
françois hollande et mme merkel ou le
document final qui est le state mais
après le après le semaine partie cela va
le mot traité transatlantique n'est pas
prononcé pourquoi parce que les
informations dont nous disposons sont
assez simples les services de la
chancelière ont exigé des français que
ce sujet ne soit pas abordée et les
français se sont couchés donc on peut
être pour ou contre
la question n'est pas là l'accord
transatlantique on est pour ou contre le
niveau de négociations qui ont pu être
obtenue ce qui est absolument scandaleux
c'est que le président de la république
française affiche en france une position
pour des raisons purement de politique
interne
mais une fois à bratislava en fait il se
couche et obéit aux injonctions d'un
certain nombre de c2c de nos voisins
parce qu'il n'a parce que tout
simplement il est extrêmement isolées
alors revenu à paris françois hollande a
dit mais c'est vrai je n'en ai pas parlé
mais vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir dans dix jours c'est et hier il ya
un deuxième train deuxième réunion des
magnans bratislava au niveau ministériel
avec les ministres du commerce extérieur
donc la réunion a bien eu lieu
et là on a vu c'était la fin de la
fessée déculottée
la france s'est retrouvé totalement
isolé avec l'autriche qui l'a qui l'a
aidé dans cette cette demande de
cessation des négociations mais sinon
les autres états membres ont considéré
qu'il fallait continuer donc la france
a été doublement humilié dans cette
affaire il ya quinze jours simplement
parce que président de la république n'a
même pas pu évoquer un sujet qui lui
semblait tenir beaucoup à coeur
et hier où le ministre français faute
d'avoir préparé le terrain et d'avoir un
soutien politique fort du président en
fait a été extrêmement isolé et repartis
la tête basse de cette négociation peu
glorieuse ce qu'ils expriment en fait ce
que nous disons ici de très souvent
c'est que la france ont fait disparaître
des écrans radars et subit l'europe et
n'est plus une force de persuasion
notre illustration date dérive entière
avant-hier l'autriche et l'allemagne ont
convoqué une conférence européenne sur
l'immigration avec plusieurs pays
européens se met informel plusieurs pays
européens membres de l'union hainaut
membres de l'union et bien dans ce
sommet la france n'était même pas invité
donc on est passé à un cran
supplémentaire qui fait que le couple
franco-allemand a été complètement
disloqué et madame merkel active une
politique qu'elle croit être bonne sans
même en référé aux français je pense que
nous n'avons jamais vu ça en fait depuis
là depuis traité de rome
c'est absolument ahurissant